[Music]
ride through the city like BR I'm on a
mission to get it ride through the city
like BR if you ain't please don't and
now
Brandon six
boy
sh what is popping fam it is Monday
morning November 27th 900 a.m. on the
freaking
dot that's what we do kiddos we start on
time here
that's what we have to do how was you
guys Thanksgiving
weekend great that is fantastic chin
case what' you guys do family just
family just a normal
turkey we had kimchi we had some Korean
food but mostly turkey with kimchi yeah
all right that's we that helps with
digestion right kind of but you know
what messes me up the most and I love
the most is stuffing no stuffing but it
it I was just telling Casey it messes my
body up bad afterwards like no
indigestion you be farting yeah whatever
case what did you do got the whole squat
the I was farting man slamming that
stuffing and just ripping them you were
with the fam yeah down in s dieg yeah
they got the little kids so like you
know I'm with the Bros so we're up late
drinking wine and then the kids are like
we don't care it's five let's play yep
like okay right on kids kids do not
sleep in dog they don't care they don't
sleep in I had an eventful uh
Thanksgiving didn't really get a
Thanksgiving uh most you know this my
girl's been pregnant for hot second now
and the baby was supposed to come like
mid late December and then the baby said
nah you got Thanksgiving plans I don't
care I want out and I want out now so on
Monday she went in for just a routine
checkup and then I was like yo what time
you coming home she's like I don't know
they're like having me do these other
tests I'm like what's up she's like my
blood pressure is kind of high I'm like
what's kind of high she's like it's like
180 I'm like 180 over what she she told
me I was like oh that's not safe she's
like yeah apparently they're freaking
out I'll keep you posted I'm like we
didn't think it was anything next call I
got in the middle of the night was like
hey they got to do emergency surgery now
I'm like what so I rushed over there
sure enough they had to do that
emergency C-section got that Critter out
of there but she's uh you know she's a
preey so she's about 4 weeks early
there's complications with that there's
complications with the blood blood blood
pressure of wifey because with that high
blood pressure they can pass out it's
dangerous for the baby so that's why
they decided to get the baby out of
there but um you know they had to give
her some sort of it wasn't blood
pressure medication it was like a
magnesium but I guess that can affect
the baby too so they had to give it to
her just in case because her blood
pressure is so freaking high so that
affects the baby so the baby comes out
and um it was different than my other
two kiddos cuz they were giants when
they came came out and they were they
were cooking for the expected time
before that turkey was done and so when
you it's a prey baby there's a it's
different like the baby was in the the
this like bubble the whole time they're
like doing all this stuff they they're
they're
smaller and then it's weird because you
go from that to like I said previously
with my two other uh kiddos we we went
home from the hospital two days later
like mama's with baby all the whole
family's there now it's a premum not
when there's certain issu so it's like
the baby comes out and then it you know
you're there with it they're doing all
the test and then they put in the nicku
unit and then you're just chilling
without a kiddo so then uh wifey's blood
pressure came down but being a preey
they you know they're not supposed to
come out early that's not the plan that
wasn't the big man's plans upstairs but
you know that blood pressure had to get
out so the the babyy still in the Nick
unit everything was all good
everything's all good and they like yeah
maybe the baby come home on uh Saturday
and you can call and check in on the
baby and they also have a monitor
fulltime so you can watch it so we're
like watching like you know some helicop
their parents and then uh we check in at
8:00 a.m. every morning that tells how
she did through the night and she's like
yeah she's eating she was on oxygen cuz
her lungs weren't fully developed but
now she's breathing on her own we're
like all right cool and then they're
like and you know her body temperat she
holding body temperature like all right
cool and then we call on Saturday like
she had she had their exact word she had
an episode last night like oh God and so
they're like yeah her body temperature
went down and her uh heart rate went
down but then she fought on her own it
came back so you know she's not ready to
go like okay cool like maybe tomorrow
call again at 8: a.m. on Sunday morning
my son's my youngest son who's for his
birthday party I'm like this be a great
present for bossy they want to see their
sister so bad they haven't seen her the
only person that sold the baby is my
wife for 2 minutes cuz you know she has
to be in that weird bubble call Sunday
morning morning same thing had an
episode last night at midnight like [__]
same
thing so at this point you you're just
wish him for the best and hopefully the
you know the kiddos a prey so they're
not supposed to be out so it is tough
around the shop household not going to
lie to you guys it's been a tough week
man but I've never prayed so much in my
life I'm not a religious person when
stuff goes down like that it's all you
can really do man but um the shout out
to the docs at Cedar Cyanide and they
know what they're doing and um yeah just
hope for the best I'm sure to work out
and she's new so she's not supposed to
be here right now she's supposed to be
cook another 3 weeks so she's cooking
that little uh incubator device there
and hopefully she fights through it and
she'll be all right she's already a
feisty one so I think she'll be okay but
yeah it's tough man it was a tough long
long week so it is what it is man my
Thanksgiving dinner my family was gone
they're at the hospital they have to
come back and uh get bags and stuff for
the kiddos so my thing Thanksgiving
dinner was straight up a large pepperoni
pizza I told you guys man I like to mix
it up and it was I thought it was going
to be cool so I had a large pepperoni
pizza and watched twin flames on
Netflix not cool man it's kind of sad
not cool not as cool as I thought having
Thanksgiving Pizza dinner by yourself is
not cool surprise uh yeah yeah yeah
breaking news not cool it's kind of sad
pizza was delicious and I ha myself
after I ate it but that's where we're at
that's where we're at fam been on a
strict diet getting ready for this kiddo
and uh decided to depress eat that large
pepperoni pizza from Domino's and
Domino's shout out to them being open on
Thanksgiving I me they got that pizza
about 25 minutes piping hot I devoured
that thing and I felt awful I felt
absolutely terrible been a slow uh let's
get into the fights man uh news on the
truck my truck goes in the Ford
Lightning goes in tomorrow to my boy
Eddie at addiction to get that thing
figured fig out so I've been Countdown
the days on that bad boy so I cannot
wait to figure out what's going on with
that and unravel that bad boy and get to
work on it so when I say get to work
means find the best people for the job
and watch them do the work because I
don't know what I'm doing but it's still
fun uh so that's the news on the
lightning man we'll figure out we'll
know tomorrow I'll keep you guys posted
I'm sure I'll post something we'll know
tomorrow as far as fight news goes again
I told you guys this the offseason for
fighting pfl had their thing that nobody
watched and paid for but still they did
their thing shout out to Brunson he he
got paid and uh did his thing um but
outside that this is the offseason for
the for the major leagues for for the
NFL this is the off for the UFC which is
the NFL this is the off season right now
but it ramps up this Saturday you got
quite the freaking you're quite the
fight night in Austin
Texas uh a great this could be like a
lowlevel pay-per-view where people
complain about it but it's a great card
where people talk all that mess about
this pay-per-view I'm not paying for
this but you pay for it and turns out to
be the best card of the Year this is one
of those but it's a fight night so it's
free technically it's not payview you
still gotta pay for ESPN plus you know
what I'm saying though it's still a
fight night you got darush uh versus
Armen which is a phenomenal fight Jaylen
Turner stepping in on short notice
against Bobby green absolutely love that
fight Rob font versus figorito have you
seen figorito lately
no cheers old son Jack City for his
bantamweight uh debut there you got Sean
Brady Kelvin gastam that's sick probably
my favorite fight on the card not going
to lie to you um Klay Guida back at it
every bit of 50 years old and looking
phenomenal with the craziest gas tank of
all time you got Mesa Tate doing the
damn thing never mad when she fights uh
Zack ree
dra Veronica Hardy Dan Hardy's wife
who's a a badass she is she's a super
badass chin likes her not going to lie
she's very pretty chin has a crush chin
has a crush tell tell Dan Hardy whip
your ass um but yeah that's going down
in Austin I'm surprised Rogan doesn't do
this one even though it's a fight night
it's literally in his backyard you know
and this would be the five night to do
it too it's stack this is I would pay
for this more than I would the
pfl yeah yeah people got some nerve
charging money from when I saw that I
was like
oh that that's why uh the beer knuckle
MMA does it right because when you're
trying to get a promotion off the ground
M like you you got to get people to tune
it's tough enough there's so much
content out there's so much to compete
with so you can't say this is only if
you pay
$50 because most casual fans like I
don't know who that is I don't pay for
that so you have people invested in the
first place p knuckle MMA goes we're GNA
give it to you tell us if you like it
then eventually down the road if these
guys become big stars or if you guys
want to watch them then maybe you pay
for it but right now just tell us what
you think of the product hundreds of
thousands of views millions of views
across social media millions of
views now can you imagine if they went
nope it's 100 bucks all right all right
here's 3,000 weirdos they're going to
pay for this thing because we have
nothing going on you
know okay that one's $49.99 but this is
totally worth it though oh no that's no
so this where you're getting confused
this is beer
knuckle this is mikc bkfc is different
no you're talking about Jorge mazal I'm
talking about Jorge mazal and Deans
their thing is here tell us what you
think of it view it tell you know tell
us what you think of production the
fights and then eventually down the road
you're going to get there be Knuck has
been around for a hot second and also
Mike Perry Alvarez take my money dude
the card's pretty sick stack dud it's a
good weekend of fights it's been a slow
few weeks but between be knuckle and
then that fight night Austin it's
fantastic fantastic you also got my boy
Todd Duffy fighting Ben
Rothwell uh only uh advice you give give
you Todd don't uh fake a singer leg and
then throw a Jon Jones spinning back
elbow and rock him and then the game
plans to drag him in later rounds but
you get too excited because you're
immature and didn't stick to a game plan
and then just Wing shots from your hips
and hope you don't get hit in the jaw
don't do that that's the only advice I
can give you because it doesn't end well
in Atlanta all right when Rashad and Jon
Jones in the main event don't do that be
smart my man that's a I mean that's
going to be a fun fight Beck Rollins
fighting on that
too it it could just be Perry and Eddie
and I'd pay 50 bucks Jeremy Stevens and
Rivera too oh
damn
schnikes how's that not your co-main
event
yeah Mike P Alvarez a Fant The
Underground King bear knuckle yeah and
he won against remember Chad mes was
killing it yeah but Eddie Alvarez Eddie
for a tough fight for Mike
Perry tough fight this is a great fight
yeah best fight of the
weekend agree best fight of the weekend
I'm looking forward to that uh fight
night in Austin um so when there's uh
downtime in the
UFC Universe you're going to get a lot
of Real Housewives of Ultimate Fighter
which
means this isn't to hate on B I'm just
saying drama you you're going to get
drama cuz people are bored and you know
fire off we also don't have a big fight
to look forward to so people are going
to focus on social media so the
narrative uh that I woke up to what
maybe two days ago just everywhere
online is Sean Strickland gets on uh
Twitter I think he only just Twitter
Twitter Instagram yeah usually he's a
Twitter guy yeah I I have his Instagram
videos here though sure so whenever you
see Sean
stricklin with that straight up selfie
video and he's in his truck I don't know
what kind of truck he he drives I'd love
to find out what kind of truck guy is
but whatever whenever you see that video
you know some [__] is going down you
know he's dropping mad fire in Sean
Strickland's
way correct me if I'm wrong
here could be off I don't know all the
the Rumblings of this you know loving
fistic cops here uh episode of Real
Housewives of uh Ultimate Fighter so
Sean Strickland has a message for Ian
Gary I like both these guys I'm a huge
fan of both of them
MH so but Sean trick St is going to help
Ian Gary out right cuz again correct me
if you know if if you have your black
belt in this uh whole drama here Jen
Sean Strickland found out that Ian
Gary's wife wrote a book a long time ago
12 years ago 12 years ago on being a wag
which stands for wives and girlfriends I
didn't know had to look wives and
girlfriends of athletes right but that
that yeah that date like famous
athlet yeah why and uh girlfriends of
athletes so she wrote a book 12 years
ago on like how to cop you a man be a
wag right and then um he also found out
again I don't know who his sources I
don't know where this even came from
that's why I don't put too much into any
of this cuz you know it's all heay here
but so she wrote a Wags Book 12 years
ago and then her exboyfriend or husband
ex-husband husband lives with Ian Gary
and his his new nutritionist apparently
okay I think this is coming from this
guy named MMA Guru I'm not 100% sure but
that's what I think where it came from
he did the investigation yeah and and
how would he know do we know how I mean
he looks into all this stuff I mean he
found out that book it exists so yeah
yeah yeah I I don't know any of this I'm
not saying anybody's wrong anybody's
right I don't know any of that stuff I'm
just want to get all my facts here
before I give an opinion on it so Sean
Strickland finds us out Sean stricklin
is going to Sean Strickland this why we
love him right he just shoots from the
hip but he says he's trying to help
being Gary out
if you want to help Ian Gary out you
don't go public with this and make it
this entire [__] storm of info for Ian
Gary and his family that and they the
problem with 2024 and it used to be just
like a millennial like
Generation Z or Y or what the hell we're
on it it used to be like a young thing
where they will go after whoever like
the Jake Paul's the world you know the K
they there's no standard that
everything's on nothing's off limits
which I don't
partake in I don't like that the the
wives and family should never be touched
no matter what it is if you want to talk
about Ian Gary's jab his left hook his
te the the way he you know defends
takedowns fire away that's what he
signed up for but what he didn't sign up
for is Attack on his personal life and
his family that's where I'm like oh guys
come on but Sean strick is a Shan
Strickland my only cavey out there my
only criticism of uh Sean Strickland you
know it's good content for what we do
and all that stuff but I could care less
about that but if Sean shrier want to
actually help being Gary he would have
message him
privately that's like oh you're not
trying to help him dude like maybe you
are in a weird way but also if you're
trying to help him just anyone in the
UFC it's a small alumni it's easy to
reach out to somebody you don't go
public with it and then the fans get on
it and then Ean Gary you know has a lot
of haters you know he has a lot of
haters so when I found this I looked
into it
and the the thing that made me feel bad
how old is he and Gary 26 I think let
he's young right he's young and his
wife's 40 yep and they have a
baby I oh he's 26 26 young as hell he's
super young uh undefeated in the UFC you
have a baby yeah
um we we I just I skeptical hippo eyes
is when Ian Gary made that
video of our boy who used to work at
Texas Roadhouse Jeff Neil Jeff Neil when
he when he made that t-shirt of his mug
shot have you seen that video yeah and
you you can tell it's not in's idea and
he's like it was their idea and then
when they saw they saw oh this is Savage
and you see him pushing him to do it
push him to do it I was like oh this is
a kid who's influenced by these two
that's what it looked like now this is a
short 15 second clip into 27 years of
Ian Gary's Life 26 oh yeah 27 26 he's 26
he's 26 so 26 years of V Gary's life so
you got to hold some reservation there
who knows the whole Grand Story of it
but just everything inside looking at
that I'm like oh I don't like that that
that that doesn't seem right you know
then someone posted a a thing that she
said on Reddit where you know her
husband's ego where she says I love you
and he says I would love me too like
this weird I don't again I don't know
what's real what's not it's the internet
these days people make all sorts of crap
up so I don't know what's real but
hearing this and then when you see that
clip and you put two and two together
like o this isn't good the the only
thing here with this
is if if that works for Ian Garett
whether she was a wag and this was her
intentions to get with him who who are
we to judge that that's not real love
they have a kid together I'm sure Ian
Gary had his pick of the litter when it
comes to females so something worked
here and he's obviously crushing it he's
undefeated something they're doing is
working and maybe just cuz she had these
12 years ago these intentions to get
with an athlete and she got an athlete
that was 12 years ago maybe she changed
maybe she thought that but there's
actual a genuine connection between her
and Ian Garett even though they're you
know he's younger 26 and 40 okay we've
seen it happen before and it works out
so I'm not one to judge I here's the
other thing I don't give a [__] if Ian
Gary likes older women and she's his
manager and she direct them in this way
and influence them in this way okay why
do you guys care if that works for him
who are we to judge what works for Ian
Gary if they're in an open
relationship monogamous whatever it is
who gives a [__] all I care about is he
and Gary perform inside that octagon why
everybody want has this thing to say
about the way he deal it's his private
life man and this is where social media
gets super dark because now you're
dealing with a 26-year-old kid who's
trying to be the best fighter in the
world and now we're not talking about
his jab and his tee and his roundhouse
and his uh hook we're talking about
things that have nothing to do with
fighting and the tension on Ian Gary's
not how great of a fighter he is how
he's UND deea the UFC now all the
attention is his wife wag blood sucker
and the the you know MMA media is toxic
so everyone jumps on it so now you got
to be careful because this 26-year-old
phenom has to be the most talented 26y
oldold UFC scene in a hot goddamn second
is dealing with this [__] now
instead of getting ready for Vicente luk
if he beats vente luk who's ranked this
would be his what seventh win in a
row there's a hell of a story for him to
fight for a world title against Leon
Edwards who just kicked him out of the
gym yeah that's what we should be
focused on focus on Vicente
luk but but the the the thing is
sometimes when people shine lights on
this stuff you get at 26 if he's
influenced by this and they're tell him
to do this
stuff he he does need to step back a
second and just go okay okay hold on I'm
26 I got you know we've been together
for a while now I was very young we have
a baby forget about what the internet
says whether she's you know a gold
digger forget about all that what's
going right in my life well my training
right he's kicking ass in training he's
on a feed in the UFC his his his his
mindset is
phenomenal but the narrative on in Gary
and and he went from this you know this
babyfaced talented Prospect into this
really hated guy I feel like very
fast and a lot of it came from all
right mimicking Conor McGregor right we
know it's not authentic he's using very
same words right you don't need to do
that just being gar we don't need that
talking stuff that's fine that's fine
especially in today's age and that's his
personality he can do that but and then
the Leon Edwards stuff got a little
dicey right and that's when people
started looking into things so I I would
just step back and maybe have a
conversation with the wife and the
ex-boyfriend or ex-husband just like hey
guys the direction we're going that's
not a route I want to go and hopefully
he has that power or he has that
opportunity to express that to him like
I was beloved man and then now you guys
took me over here with the
you know the the the mug shot picture
and stuff like like that wasn't even his
idea no it wasn't yeah that's what sucks
that's what sucks so whoever's running
his stuff you're you're you're actually
not helping him you're kind of hurting
him because you have nothing to do with
the fundamentals and his training you
have nothing to do you guys are the pr
team basically and you're doing a
freaking horrible job cuz this kid has
become the most hated guy in MMA over a
3mon period with the way guys have
handled things and to add more fuel to
that
fire Sean stricken posts this then he
gets DMS from Ian Gary if you think Ian
Gary is threatening a
lawsuit I got property to sell you a
beachfront property in Nebraska that's
not that's again his PR team his wife or
her ex-husband posting even the way it's
written out that's not Ian
Gary so he this is the DMS to Sean I'm
not a lawyer I'm just a guy who's trying
to help oh so this is Sean so this is
Sean saying this I'm not a lawyer I'm
just a guy who's trying to help he put a
cuck LOL sue me get in line mother eer
there are a few in front of you I would
have respected you more if you
threatened violence against me but I
guess it makes sense then put cuck again
and then he responded Sean what you're
doing is spreading hate lies and
harassment I'm helping you here giving
you a heads
up again this this isn't going to help
the Ian uh Gary narrative
in any facet when when you're a
professional fighter and we've gone
through this with Logan Paul and Dylan
danis there I can't emphasize this
enough the number one rule in fighting
the number one rule there's no suing in
fighting a fighter can't sue another
fighter you're professional fighters the
way you handle this is you get inside
that oon and you fight cuz that's what
you do for a living now if you're a
businessman or you're an Instagram
thought or you're a model or you're a
singer or your Entertainer whatever you
are and someone's coming after you and
you can't fight then you and you want to
sue I guess go down that route but
that's your only option if you're a
professional fighter you threaten to
beat him up that's how this goes with
Dylan danis Logan Paul Logan threatens
to sue him no no no you make him pay
inside that
ring for Ian Gary should like bro I I
don't know who he it would have went so
so much further with fans and the usfc
if he went hold up he would have got so
much more respect he went hold up hold
up what me my wife do is none of your
business if you have an issue with it
I'll meet you here insert address of Jim
we'll film it we'll make it for the fans
I'm gonna beat the [__] out of
you nobody goes to prison nobody goes to
jail there's no domestic violence
there's none of this there's no assault
charges you guys are legit prize
Fighters act like it fight each other
they're not that far off in size in
Gary's a massive
massive Strickland's not the big I mean
he's don't get me wrong he's big 85 but
still you we could figure this out if
you have so much hate you're both pretty
damn good at fighting do what you do
best fight each other the UFC would be
foaming at the mouth to make this okay
and foring Gary bro here's the path you
beat viente luki luk you call out Sean
Strickland maybe you land on Leon
Edwards either way you're fighting for a
title but instead what' we do your wife
and her ex-husband decide to threaten a
lawsuit well now we can't mess with that
there's we can't all right game over we
can't do anything with
it you have one of the very best
welterweights in the world has all the
potential all the goddamn the most
potential we've seen in freaking years
this kid can do this man he has so much
goddamn Talent what he did to Neil Magny
was freaking insulting disrespectful
it's how talented this kid
is you have all the potential in the
world
dude you're just going about it the
wrong way and I don't know again I don't
know what's going on in his world I
don't know what his mindset is if they
have so much influence over him you're
not doing a good job you're ruin this
kid's career
you got to let him fight and you know
what makes even if you are a gold digger
I'm not saying you are even if you are
you know what makes him more money
becoming world champion you know what
doesn't make him world champion suing
another world champion you know what
makes him a world champion whooping his
ass whether it's in the Octagon or it's
at Ruka or it's at the gym in Vegas or
it's in thick boy Studios you whoop his
ass we can't get a sanction here I'd
probably have a lawsuit but no here no
there go go to any freaking gym you want
do at the Gracie Academy for all I care
whatever you got to do fight each other
that's what you guys do best not only do
your best you're two of the best to
freaking do
it suing again Ian Gary probably had no
clue he's he probably woke up like whoa
why are people thinking I'm suing the
guy and she's like that's what we told
him to take it down oh my God you're 40
figure out social media take it down
once things are out they're out there's
no taking it down once sits out even if
he deletes it it doesn't matter it's
already in the Twitter verse that thing
will live forever he could take it down
it doesn't matter the the the trolls the
family and then they have it once it's
out there's no deleting so that's not
even an option in's 26 he knows this The
40-Year-Old and however old her ex
husband is has no clue how this works
you're ruin the kid's career off your
stupid PR moves there's so much at stake
care that kid can do it and you're
[__] it up that kid can do it and you
could have used this opportunity to gain
some fans and to gain some respect and
go cool bro send me your address I'm
gonna drive down there and beat the [__]
out of you we'd all go damn you wouldn't
watch that you wouldn't watch on
Instagram live or Tik Tok live or
Twitter live Ian Gary pulls up at Sean
Strickland's gym five round sparring
two-minute
break what
$29.99 we make
merch what there's so much opportunity
here but you wasted it you threatened
lawsuit number one rule in prize
fighting you don't Sue each other I
can't emphasize enough you young
Fighters or current Fighters if you're
watching this that's the last thing you
want to do nobody's going to jump on
board on that you're a prize fighter the
way you handle your business is you beat
the other guy up especially if you're
only one weight class difference I can
understand if it's Mighty Mouse talking
[__] to Francis Gano okay you might have
to sue him but if it's Francis and Gano
talking stuff to insert light
heavyweight you guys aren't that far off
punch each other in the face and we're
talking business it's good for the UFC
it's good for you it's good for him
suing is good for nobody it's good for
the
lawyers for in Gary he needs to wake up
morning go whoa get the wife and the
next up go what the [__] are you two
doing you are ruining my career and has
nothing to do with fighting not only
does it have nothing to do with fighting
but now you're deflecting a way I gotta
fight V sente
luk so now they need to be sitting
around all right you beat vente luk
which I think you will hopefully he does
remember he's 26 dealing with this this
just toxic evil stuff non-stop question
his family question his wife question is
nutritionist who's his wife's ex-husband
so weird if this is all real saying we
don't know I know who knows so all this
stuff is coming in he's 26 he has to
figure that out here's the good news if
you figure all that out you get through
this [__] storm that you're dealing with
and you head kick viente luk you get on
that mic and you rip the hottest
freaking promo calling out Sean
Strickland and Leon Edwards going yeah
you you you B rabbit you ate mile this
thing and go yeah my nutritionist did
used to [__] my wife yeah you old school
this thing dude take the power back yeah
my nutrition iade weight used to [__] my
wife yeah he lives with this yeah my
wife wrote this Wags book and we still
here Sean Strickland come get some UFC
300 Leon Edwards yeah I did get kicked
out of the gym big deal I'm glad I got
kicked out I'll see UFC
307 double champ who wants it mic drop
merch money different
narrative or you can keep doing what
you're doing and sliding dude's DMS and
threatening lawsuits which we can't run
with here you need a you I'm not saying
fire your wife might be saying fire your
nutritionist if all that's true what I'm
saying is hire a PR team or talk to the
UFC who's the best PR team in the world
and go how can we change this narrative
right now and I guarantee you they're
very they're way smarter than I am
they're gonna go call out Shan
Strickland after you beat vente
luk right now it's a distraction beat
vente Luke call it Sean strickley and
Leon Edwards you're only going to fight
those two next all you care about is
getting vengence on Sean Strickland and
beating Leon Ed for kicking out of the
gym now we're cooking with s
baby this is you got the perfect
comeback story you take out both those
guys we could retire if we want
to and you're your your your Northstar
Conor McGregor that's exactly what he
would do Conor doesn't threaten lawsuit
did khabib threaten lawsuit when he
threw the
dolly some of the fires got hit with
glass in the eye whatever that's nor
here over there but did did did kabib no
khabib was like I'm going to whoop your
ass
dude and what' he do he jumped over the
yeah there's no lawsuit Dagan law
suit they don't do
that no he freaking jumped out of the
cage and freaking Spartan kicked Dylan
danis in the
face that's how you handle this and then
UFC ran with it bro ran with fre and
Gary dude you do what you do best kick
people's asses don't hire lawyers number
one rule in prize fighting is we don't
threaten lawsuit you're not going to win
anybody over you punch him in the
[__] mouth and you can do it and not
get arrested oh my God you got the best
job in the world dude so Sean strigin
get has all this heat right now he has
all this Fame go for that guy take his
fan base whoop his
ass I get Sean Strickland's your
huckleberry you get the perfect opponent
to do it the perfect opponent to do it
Sean shri's like say less bro pull
up don't threat in the lawsuit though
there's nothing there Bubba you got you
got to quit listening to who maybe it's
not your wife and ex-husband maybe it's
not them maybe it's some weird PR team
in Orange County who's
like you
know Mark Zuckerberg right I don't know
but h fire them whoever it is I don't
give a [__] if it's your mom your
brother your sister fire them and the
narrative here it's it's set up for you
my man and you have all the talent in
the world to do it but we got to beat
viente luk you got we need an impressive
KO win and Bubba we are off to the races
you're going to win so many people over
if you can handle this [__] storm you're
dealing with and perform at that next
UFC in December bro I'm telling you the
the table set my man you caught Sean
Strickland you caught Leon Edwards you
be rabbit you be rabbit you ate my this
thing mom spaghetti sweaty Palms you
feel me you be rabbit this you're the
white guy in Detroit with all black guys
right and you B rabbit this thing that's
exactly what we do but right now you're
not B rabbit in this you're you're
cheddaring this situation you're
shooting yourself in the freaking leg
don't be cheddar this don't shoot
yourself in the leg be Eminem of your
movie don't be cheddar don't be Cheddar
Bob don't be Cheddar Bob because right
now you're shooting yourself in the leg
give a hot promo after you knock out
with sente luk we forget all about it
you fight Sean Strickland you fight Leon
Edwards boom biggest star in the UFC and
he has the talent to do it that's what's
great if you didn't have the talent yeah
threaten lawsuit do your thing dude this
kid can freak this kid can that's the
best thing about this that's why I'm
excited about this kid can [__] fight
dude this kid can fight his ass off this
dude's so goddamn talented that's what's
great about this if he's not we don't
have a I have nothing to rip on here I
have nothing but he's he's a once in a
generation Talent that's what we're
dealing with here he can do this you got
to have the right messaging you right
the markeing team the fighting is taking
care of itself you can handle that
you've you've made it this far the rest
stuff you got to figure out Bubba you
have
to
binem not cheddar
bom and take and seeing and seene two
things about this real quick uh
so the one thing I didn't like that Sean
said is like he said Sean said like be a
man I would respect you more if you went
to a Bass Pro Shop got a 9mm and came
over I'm like that's not being a man
that's being again no no they're both
off no you're you're going too extreme
stly I know that's his thing
again second rule of Fight Club there's
no guns yeah dude what the hell was that
that was it didn't make any sense first
rule fight club we don't Sue second rule
of Fight Club we don't shoot each other
again your weapons are these and those
these and those not these first rule
don't Sue second rule don't shoot it's
all you follow those rules we're going
sizler so Strickland's off in Gary's off
one's suing one wants to shoot uh-uh
you're both completely off
you're both the top prize fighters in
the
world [__] fight each
other yeah this isn't hard to figure out
dude fight each other yeah that's great
Leon and Strickland that would be great
take my money so the last thing on this
is uh Chris Curtis who's actually one of
Strickland's he's Strickland's like best
friend pretty much I love him he
defended Ian Gary and it got to the
point where so many people went after
him he deactivated his Twitter account
well he's associated with Sean stri and
he was defending Ian Gary he's like yeah
Ian has this you know whatever that's
his life he's saying the same stuff but
Chris Curtis is right he's right he goes
y'all need to chill withan Gary thing um
man has a life that's unconventional to
you all supposedly who knows but it's
his life and it works for him preach
people are giving his wife ship for a
book she wrote 12 years ago IA is a
grown man and you're a fool if you don't
think they
haven't they haven't
what wait a girl I don't
know but uh even Strickland posted
C Ian's wife got to Curtis some some
give Curtis a wellness check yeah cuz he
had it deactivated his yeah d man he was
just saying like you know he's just his
Twitter account is basically giving a
platform to people that are talking
smack so he's like why bother with it
you know and he has a fight coming up
he's like I don't need this talk and
stuff I'm logging off for a little bit I
get it yeah that's all I get it that's
all for that but you if your boy going
like just don't say anything dude but
again he's a grown ass man he's like
Whoa We can't go after wives here dude
I'm I'm all on board for the rest of the
stuff but the other things I'm not
boarded for of course Sean Str fans like
kill him then Mike Perry did his do you
see his oh you didn't see uh Perry Oh
look up Perry imit Johan strickler oh I
saw that it's so good yeah
yeah well I'm not doing the man dance
it's so good he's all
America it's good Mike Perry's a
freaking Legend he's such a personality
yeah um it's a YouTube video so I don't
know if we could do this right I bet
social no it's a it's on social media
let's do
this hold up guys Des Strickland here
and when I'm not being a total badass in
the cage doing the man dance doing the
man dance talking [__] on social media
about other people and their beliefs and
relationships stuff that's the only baby
all the way white what's up
guys so here's the
thing that's funny
yeah all right Jim what do you got oh
actually let's do some uh give me one
sec here quick break ad
reads so first one
meter meter let's take a little break
here the holidays are finally here boy
are they here we get to stuff our faces
eat like there's no tomorrow even it's a
pepperoni pizza by yourself on
Thanksgiving crying and Shop the best
sales of the year and I know the coolest
product to cook your meals that also
makes for the perfect gift especially
for all them dads out there I'm talking
about meter that's m a t r Tow Mater
we're talking about meter it's a really
slick smart meat thermometer that tracks
the of your meat let you know when it's
ready to come out of the oven that's
when I know it's time to get my meat off
Chin's Grill all right this way you
never undercook or overcook that holiday
turkey there's never a good time to cook
a turkey or juicy prime rib or them
fillets my kids love to eat all right
the whole family's like dang Chef boardd
the app even estimates how long your
cook will take and gives you a countdown
so you know how long you have to kick
back spend time with your loved ones or
make an oldfashioned you'll get an alert
when your food is ready to eat my papa
uses these things and his meat is
fantastic I go by the old method I just
the old feel technique it's not proven
science I'd much prefer Meer all right
uh it comes with Cloud Server so you can
have Limitless range you can monitor the
cook while watching TV or running to the
store this is the perfect tool for your
holiday cooking also makes the perfect
gift for someone who loves a Cooker
grill and put meat on your grill all
right shop meter.com that's me a
t.com for the best kitchen tool out
there get your meat just right all right
start shopping for the Christmas gifts
all them dads who constantly put their
meat on your grill make sure it's the
perfect meat that's m a t r.com all
right meter perfect meat on your
grill listen when I started podcasting
an online store was the furthest thing
from my mind me and my brother were
doing fireing kid merch shipping out of
my small apartment or my brother's room
it got very taxing all right and uh I
wish we had Shopify yep once we switched
to Shopify got so much easier because we
use Shopify Ching all right it's so
freaking easy shopy is the global
Commerce platform that helps you sell at
every stage of your business from the
launch your online shop stage which I
was at about 12 years ago to the first
real life store stage all the way to did
we just hit a million orders stage
Shopify is there to help you grow
Shopify helps you turn over browser into
buyers with the internet's best
converting check out up to 36% better
compared to other leading Commerce
platforms Shopify Powers 10% of all
e-commerce in the US shopify's Global
force behind all birds rothy and Brook
linen the millions of other
entrepreneurs of every size across 175
countries all right plus they have great
support service because business that
grow grow with Shopify sign up for $1
per month trial period at shopify.com
shopall lowercase seab all lowercase go
to shopify.com shab all lowercase shabab
now to grow your business no matter what
stage you're in shopify.com shopall
lowercase Ching
nice all right so this one's a little
bit deeper into the MMA world but so the
there's an inju injective relief on the
UFC antitrust case that's been going on
and um it's hard for me to dive deep in
this but this is what bloody elbow
reported
recent report from bloody elbow we all
take that with a grain of salt here uh
note that the judge Richard F bware
refused several UFC motions that were
viewed as an attempt to delay the start
of the trial not only that he decided
that the Lee PL PLS could see injunctive
relief based on results of their case
there will be no waiting for a second
case from kjun Johnson kjun Johnson
covering the time period following 2017
before changes unfair business practice
may be forced upon the UFC the judge not
the jury could order changes the UFC's
Behavior it will be decided immediately
after Lee case if the PLS win selling
that case has a lot more stake and it's
a lot risky for the UFC whoa and it goes
into more detail here
well right here injunctive relief could
change a lot of things for example
there's a lot of restrictive language in
the UFC contracts preach there's the
judge has uh commented on pass rulings a
simple change like requiring contracts
to last no longer than two years would
make a huge change yep because they're
six years now his rulings could break
the UFC's iron grip on all the top
athletes in the sport whoa and then
there the last part here the UFC can
just take out loan loans out and the
loans would pay for the damages and then
they'd have to pay the loans off which
would be much cheaper per year but with
injunctive relief it's like your big
name Fighters might certainly be leaving
the promotion then you're most then
you're not as valuable as promotion
anymore whoa so if if the plaintiffs win
the UFC could lose billions and then
that could be like a you know Snowball
Effect for everything else too and with
pfl
you know taking on bellor and they Saudi
money and all that stuff you got you
know be knuckle MMA Saudi Arabia is
probably the biggest thing for uh yeah
because they can sign anyone they have
the most money they have the money so if
they're like hold up insert Tom Aspen
Ian Gary um Leon Edwards you know all
sugar Shan these big name Fighters if
the contracts up they're saying hey Max
going to do his two years these guys get
free that's why it's a big deal because
then they become free agent saudi's like
we'll pay him 15 mil MH they have them
they have all the money so then all of a
sudden you start getting these key
Fighters going to the other promotion
and it could grow and grow and grow and
yeah it's
possible yeah we'll see we'll see what
happens with the lawsuit that's kind of
crazy it's going this far all right so
there's rumors uh the pfl I guess Co
president said that um they're looking
at Deontay Wilder versus Francis zanu in
the pfl in 2024 with like a mixed rules
thing not straight up boxing or anything
this is a home run for pfl because
obviously Francis quote unquote beat
Tyson Fury that rematch not help
happening next he has to fight usyk so
Francis is a huge Dame huge commodity in
in our sport but if he was just going to
fight some no Namer doesn't make sense
he has to fight a boxer he's a boxer now
so pfl went all right what can we rank
number 10 in WBC yeah rank number 10 the
world boxer for God's sakes so pfl went
what can we do we're not really a boxing
promotion what if there was a top 10
boxer who's willing to play the game and
maybe cross promote do some different
mix rules and Deontay Wilder said I'll
do it dude pfl take my this would be
huge for the pfl this how you know the
Saudis have the money because Deontay
Wilder is not cheap but he's willing to
play this
game it's a home run for pfl this would
you can charge for a pay-per-view for
this we all know Francis we all know
Deontay Wilder both pay-per-view
Commodities okay this makes sense
Saturdays [__] you sorry
c um all right
so unfortunately Dan hooker hasn't you
know hand injury so thankfully um Jaylen
Turner stepped in to fight Bobby green I
think fight great fight great fight
that's a great fight also uh we thought
this was going to be in LA but this is
going to be in Orange County so UFC 298
it's going to be Alexander volkanovski
versus ilot Aura in
Anaheim o
and they were thinking like I'm so
curious how that fight's going to go
down mhm that's such a tough fight for
Alexander especially after getting yeah
tough tough fight
yeah but yeah that's in February so are
we potentially doing a fight companion
yeah that's the plan all right why is
that what you guys were talking about
fight companion yeah we were like
wondering cuz it's it's like a local
thing so it' be pretty cool if we did it
here I mean all the UFC fighters be
taken out but we'll figure it out yeah I
don't know could be a worst time to a
fight no I'm saying for us cuz we're
local thought about that no I'm saying
we're local there so many UFC fighters
in town yeah not that I'm saying like
it's cool cuz it's like it's in our
state in our area
vicinity not two hours as well be in Abu
Dhabi yeah it would help us out I go
there every weekend man it's not that
far but anyway um all right so this is
another cool one you whoa great fight so
yeah Hermanson Jack Hermanson versus Joe
Piper Joe their headliner for February
10th that's the fight night great fight
night
yeah all righty and
then this is pretty crazy I know right
so Anthony Smith is replacing I honestly
I don't remember this fighter but osot
muranov he was supposed to fight khil
rry but something happened with him so
now Anthony Smith is fighting KH rry
assum Fight Night winner of that has a
pretty good shot at getting the
champ I
mean yeah light heavyweight is kind of
like up in the it's up in the air yeah
but that's that's a cool fight that's a
great fight that's a tough one to call
Tough fight great fight yeah both
awesome dudes
too um I think let's see oh we already
we kind of cover the pfl already but
Olivia auin Mercy I think he won like
three in a row or something crazy in pfl
like he's a millionaire now he's good he
wanted to he's like yeah I'm kind of
done with it he he doesn't feel the
butterflies anymore good for him so he's
going to yeah he retired wow shout out
to him went out on top good for him
yeah um Katy Taylor won over the weekend
she was an underdog which is kind of
cool yeah cuz she lost her last one uh
yeah I think the first one that she
fought against her but there was like a
Tik Tok video but I just I'm too afraid
to play it Conor McGregor reacting to it
so people could Google it or you know
research but he looked like he was
just on everything well I was going to
say he looked like he was booming with
he
on everything whatever dude which is
fine dude he can do what he wants get
your mind out of the gutter just
be can't be happy anymore casy is such
getc everyone's like oh he's jumping too
high he's on cocaine if you watch the
video but Casey loves Connor so I get we
all do we yeah of course but I'm saying
Casey's does sound like you do Chen
whatever you guys celebrating of his
friends win you're like he's on cocaine
yeah I mean that's fine he's not
fighting anyway uh so this was was kind
of funny uh people started reacting to
seeing uh yam uh Mario masaki at the pfl
and do you remember the last I think he
was kicked out of the UFC because he let
a fight go on way too long with
Valentina shevchenko and Priscilla
kosher he's like you he want to see him
die he's like we is he the only guy to
get kicked up like hey man we can't do
this anymore we're trying to get
sponsors you got guys literally dying
yeah I think the stats showed like it
was like 200 unanswered strikes or 200
like what I wanted to like be Warrior
why can't I have a job I don't get why I
can't work here I did my job um there's
people just till death when they found
him he's like staring in the crowd guys
are just getting knock off oh yeah stop
guys stop it's just
funny pfl better have their head on a
swivel man is that it that's it uh and
we have some fights I think you already
covered a yeah we the fight night boxing
it's a happy hippo oh my favorite I'm on
it right now that ridiculous rant Eight
Mile rant of Ian gar is brought to you
by happy hippo however you get your Crum
powders shots gummies uh KPS they got it
freaking all for you it's the One-Stop
shop for the katum shop all right it's
happy hippo.com promo code is thick 23
for 20% off for a life shirt with a
friend makes a perfect holiday gift
you're thinking about trying and creatum
I wouldn't go anywhere else but happy
hippo they got it all literally whatever
you're looking for powders gummies
tablets Taffy K dips uh energy shots
highly concentrated shots and delicious
flavors it's my favorite product that I
use it's happy hippo.com promo code is
thick 23 for 20% off for Life share it
with a friend give it to as Christmas
gifts however you want to do it but it's
the best it's happy hippo.com promo code
is thick 23 and Brandon I'm just getting
word here that there's a Cyber Monday
deal so take 30% off everything it's the
biggest sale of 2023 no you didn't Casey
you're like a small Santa Claus that's
right Cyber Monday happy hippo get you
some 30% off what
yeah all right we kind of covered the
fights already but yeah so we have a few
fights obviously you have the UFC Fight
Night Austin you got beer knuckle Perry
vers uh The Underground King and Eddie
Alvarez you got Ben rthro Todd Duffy you
got Jeremy Stevens fighting you also got
Ryan Garcia coming back you got Adrien
Broner I'm excited for Garcia and
Broner there's a lot going on a lot of
fist cuffs a lot of drama I'm in Chicago
that's next week that's Friday Saturday
only December 8th and 9th that's Chicago
baby downtown Chicago two shows Friday 7
9:30 two shows Saturday 7 9:30 them bad
boys almost sold out Chicago let's go
baby give my Ryan Samberg on Chicago is
next week Friday and Saturday only and
and then the keep on trucking tour kicks
off in Nashville January 25th one night
one show only in Nashville at Zan's
there and then that Friday and Saturday
I'm in Austin Texas January 26th and
27th get your tickets right now at thick
boo.com get you some is that it that's
it all right guys love you remember
there's no soon and fighting there's
sure as hell no shooting each other
that's it be safe good luck out there be
nice to each other I'm
out
all